let's stick with the phones at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
why don't we jump to it into a call from
the three one seven area code three one
seven caller tell us your name and where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today
Maurice I live in Bloomington Indiana
great and I have unsaved two questions
the first is I'm sure you've gotten all
the other questions at this point
my first is how do we respond to Trump
stirs trumpets whatever you want to call
them to continue despite this evidence
given up by the Trump campaign
themselves to think that Trump is the
best thing that has ever happened to
this country yeah you know Murray want
to say that Hillary is the worst and all
of that yeah I think that it is by and
large a lost cause because as we see the
trickle down of the Trump approval
rating this tells us that there are some
people out there there are some trumpets
who are being influenced by what they
are learning about the guy they voted
for at this point if you have not
changed your mind on Trump you're
ideologically committed right you bought
it and you own it now and you're
responsible for the breaking of so many
aspects of the United States at this
point that I actually don't think it's
worth investing any time and trying to
talk a trumpet into anything and if
you're trying to have electoral results
as a result of what's been going on
Murray you are way better off trying to
get people who didn't vote to vote then
convincing trumpets to change their mind
it's a much better use of time I
wouldn't worry at this point if you're
still a committed trumpet you're either
as I've said before a bad person you
don't know what's going on or you lack
some kind of cognitive ability to
recognize what it is that's going on
it's not worth investing time in
changing people's minds who fall into
those camps I you're making a lot of
good points and I think you're right I
think that at least for me the reason
why I asked that question is because I
have
I'm married to somebody who thinks Trump
is the best thing that's ever happened
this country can't vote
so yeah wait a second so let me let's
talk to you Murray let me let me handle
so your marry someone will say for Tom
just Lisa torsade yeah yeah you're
married to someone who's equation but
they didn't vote for Trump they didn't
vote at all he's not an American citizen
yet he's a legal resident of the United
States
he cannot legally yet vote what time is
aa frumpy Chucky hated China okay Wow
you're a new whole different ideology
yeah what issue which does he identify
what comes most done like many legal
immigrants who support trunk that I've
either heard about or had conversations
with it had to do with illegal
immigration many legal immigrants come
here and they have worked their butts
off to get here and they've done things
and they you know sleep on a floor with
their schoolbooks as pillows for months
or even years while trying to make
something of themselves
and they see illegal to use the term
loosely immigrants come and they get to
stay where in China for example illegal
immigrants say from North Korea
they're repatriated there's your step
right back yeah we don't care what your
situation was and so I think that's part
of it for many immigrants here Sanderson
engaging as a little immigrant speaking
as a legal immigrants in the United
States myself I did not come away with
that perspective hey listen Maria I've
got limited time but if I may and and by
no means am I suggesting we go into any
graphic detail does being married to a
committed trumpet when you were not does
it caused intimacy issues are you going
to put this online well yes of course I
mean this is part of the shot it makes
it it definitely does because you
have this big fight about something that
at the end of the day doesn't really
matter that much to your family it does
but it doesn't right now and you have a
huge fight and he calls you a lefty and
you call him a right-wing nut job and
you have to go to bed and sleep next to
that person and the whole time you're
steaming right and you just want to kick
your ass because how do they not see
what you see and I mean I mean if it was
it's been rough say the least it's taken
a lot if they can we just don't talk
about it anymore in order to maintain
our own sanity and I've gone to the
point where I think we're going to be
fine in the long run but like I don't
think we can talk about this ever as
long as Trump is in office and that's a
whole different level of intimacy well
that when you start just as a future
thing for yourself so for anybody else
you single when you start creating a
list of things you're not going to talk
about it's really easy to continue
adding to that list and build a wall
right yeah I mean my girlfriend's list
with me is we will not talk about the
Bachelorette we debt that's on our list
and we just I absolutely refuse to talk
about it because I don't care and I
don't think it's valid programming but
Marie thank you so much I can't imagine
being in your shoes really really
appreciate the call Wow Wow Pat I think
on that note we are going to go to a
break because that was that was
something else
thanks to everybody who called we will
take calls again